ultimately you got to put the you on
YouTube yo you can watch a thousand
Vlogs you can watch whoever the best
vloggers are you can try to imitate them
to a T and it still ain't gonna feel
right you have to find your flow you
have to find your flow and the only way
you can do that is through practicing
so if you've thought about adding
vlogging to the way that you're doing
your YouTube channels I'm excited for
today's episode of the think media
podcast because I have my friend Aaron
on demand as part of our show today if
you're brand new to the show welcome my
name is Heather Torres and you're
listening to the think media podcast is
the number one podcast where we're
helping you build your influence on
YouTube and then turn that influence
into a high income and a high profit
online business and I want to encourage
you that if today's your first time
listening to subscribe so that you can
be connected to us because we release a
brand new episode every single Tuesday
well today I'm kind of changing things
up a little bit you know we just had our
annual conference grow with video live
we had some incredible speakers and if
you want to get actually more access to
them you can go to 21videotips.com I'll
tell you more about that during today's
episode but we had an incredible speaker
Aaron on demand now Aaron On Demand is
an entrepreneur she is someone who is
Making Waves really in the vlogging
space when it comes to YouTube and she
did an incredible keynote at grow with
video live you can check out her Channel
over on YouTube and she's really a
businesswoman I love that she says she's
a Creator CEO and really over the last
several years she's grown her Vlog to
show that transformation to show how she
was able to go from just being a Creator
who graduated high school mood backing
with her parents to someone who is
massively growing a business and a brand
and her knowledge that she brought to
the stage a girl with video live I
thought would be really great to share
with you here now you know a lot of
people think that vlogging is dead and
we've even done videos on this and I
think the old school way of vlogging is
dead I think that the new school way of
doing it where you're bringing people
along for short Journeys during the day
and really having a system in place is
how vlogging can win right now but let's
define quickly what vlogging is vlogging
is just basically a storytelling aspect
storytelling way of creating content for
your viewers you can have a vlog Channel
which means that every video You're
uploading on your channel is this style
or you can actually just incorporate
vlogging into how you do your content
and I think that there's a couple
reasons why vlogging is great one it
builds a great connection with your
audience it helps them to know who you
are it helps them to go behind the
scenes with you a little bit more and it
really can help you learn how to show
things versus tell things and we're
going to talk a little bit more about
that during today's episode with Aaron
but I think it's important for us to
just understand kind of the basis the
thesis of what we're talking about today
and that is the vlogging is alive and
active if you can do it the right way in
today's episode we're going to be
walking through the five essential
ingredients to a good Vlog because you
shouldn't just grab a camera and press
record and not have a plan to go along
with it now I want to encourage you that
if you've not vlogged before this can
feel like a different way of presenting
information it can kind of actually feel
a little bit vulnerable because you're
sharing maybe aspects of your life that
you don't normally share if you do
things like talking head videos like I'm
doing right now but I think that it's
great as content creators as
entrepreneurs for us to pull back the
curtain a little bit to go deeper with
our audience and be able to bring them
along on the journey so I'm going to
play some clips from Aaron's talk that
she did from her keynote that she did
and I'm going to react to him so you and
I are going to go on this journey
together today together first thing is
reframing how you think of vlogging
foreign and not just like something easy
or fun to do which it is but it does
take work too so you've got to say these
affirmations my life is dope because I'm
in it say it y'all my life is dope
because I'm in it I am what makes my
content fire not my possessions
my space does not define who I am
and I will plan my Vlogs so that I'm
prepared and it will show up confidently
okay so right away I love that Aaron
started with that because she's talking
really about the reframing of how we
think about vlogging and you know for me
specifically I get nervous a lot of
times to Vlog is what I'm like what do I
Vlog about and then two I'm like is my
life interesting enough I really am
sitting at a desk most days so is that
interesting enough to even create
content around and I love how she even
just started with the reframing that my
life is dope and that you know I know
that I can do this and that really it's
just going to take prior planning in
order for this to be a successful Vlog
you know I think about some of my most
successful videos on my homeschool
channel are actually just Day in the
Life videos and I planned them out so
even now as I'm creating content every
single week it's mostly talking head or
going live I'm planning that content and
so the same practices need to go into
the Vlog style content so let's get into
step number two so step two is deciding
that your end goal or deciding whatever
your end goal is for your Vlog or your
channel so if you're running this
Channel about your
um business and you want to recruit more
maybe you show more of the work culture
the team Dynamic behind the scenes stuff
of what it's like your snack Pantry or
whatever like showing making your
workspace seem cool or however you want
it to seem so there can be different
goals sales if you want to sell more
stuff you know maybe you focus on
product development showing and telling
how to use your product not overlooking
these types of things and you guys it
can be folded into other fun things that
you do but these are like the primary
things that you would focus on
um brand connection so maybe you focus
on some daily to-do's or behind the
scenes of getting your business off the
ground so you can have several different
goals you can do all three of these with
a vlog Channel but it's just about
making sure that the story makes sense
okay so one of the things I love that
she's sharing is actually incorporating
your business or your business goals in
your Vlog that was a huge unlock when I
was watching this talk as Aaron was
giving a growth video live because I
thought oh so it doesn't have to be my
whole day it really is just like what
are the goals I'm focused on and what
would I want to share with other people
so if I am but right now I'm in a
recruitment phase think media is growing
we're trying to bring on editors we're
trying to bring on operations we're
trying to bring on people that can help
us grow to the next phase I could be
sharing that in the behind the scenes of
what I do in a daily you know as a daily
YouTuber or as a operator of a business
like those could be different things I
think it's really important too that she
says you want to show these things and
one of the practices as someone who
wants to get into vlogging is to
remember that you don't have to tell
people what you're doing it's not like
you're walking around like so now I'm
going to the post office so now I'm
going to sit down and have a meeting
it's you just show those things and the
storyline comes across and even there's
a pro tip that she has on her slide here
I want to read it for her audio friends
it says Pro tip think of each Vlog as an
episode in a full season the goal
dictates each episode even that framing
it that way it could be a four-part vlog
series about maybe a really cool
conference that you go to or maybe it's
a four-part series if you're a real
estate agent about the process of
finding a buyer selling the house
closing on the house and you really are
bringing your audience behind the scenes
with you maybe you are a stay-at-home
mom who's doing a cooking channel maybe
it's about going to the grocery stores
one Vlog second is actually doing the
cooking and prepping the third Vlog
could be you know how do you handle
leftovers could you make three recipes
out of it and then the fourth blog could
be how you then incorporate your
budgeting into your buying of your
groceries there's so many ways you can
do that so my question to you think
media fam is What story do you want to
tell how can you line this up with your
goals and add it into your Vlog formats
I think that's really key now let's get
into step number three okay number three
is to keep a test log if you find
yourself struggling with figuring out
what do I actually do in a day because
we're living Our Lives you know you
don't think about all the things that
you're doing
um start with writing every task down
you do for a week I know it sounds kind
of tedious but it works professionally
and personally and then break those
large tasks into tiny tasks so if you
have team meeting on there that's kind
of a big task so you might want to break
that down into prepping your meeting
agenda
reviewing kpis for the month or meeting
notes or a recap or whatever it is that
your team meeting is and you could turn
that into a whole Vlog about a team
meeting and how you prep for it or
whatever okay so breaking those big
tasks down into small tests and then
stop trying to reinvent the wheel this
is the thing that's gonna like whoo take
a lot of pressure off of you when you're
vlogging because when I when I was
starting I would be like okay well I
show myself doing this last time so now
I got to show something different this
time and something different the next
time and you don't have to do that okay
that's the great thing about vlogging is
that honey you keep recycling that
formula over and over and over again
people are going to keep watching but in
fact that is what brands you so when you
have repetition that is that creates
your brand so people know every time I
start my Vlog I say what's up beautiful
people that's part of The Branding now
because I'm not saying something
different every single time first of all
it takes too much to think about a new
intro every single video so you know you
have to think about how to make my life
easier and knowing that repetition and
routine built trust so if you make a cup
of coffee every single morning or if you
do whatever you do every single day if
you pray in the morning if you go and
you sit and you you know you work out or
do yoga like show those parts because
those are the things that people are
going to build those connection points
off of okay first off repetition and
routine build trust that's a fire quote
right there that's tweetable from Aaron
repetition and routine builds trust and
this man this is what I struggle with
the most when it comes to vlogging and
I'm I'm sure if you're listening to this
this might be the struggle point for you
as well to really try and figure out
like what do I include in my Vlogs yes
you've signed up and you're like I want
to Vlog two you're like Hey how do I
actually do this I don't really even
know what I should be including and
that's my main struggle point and even
thinking about you know every day I'm
pretty much just sitting at a computer
running the company and then some days
I'll be live most days I'm prepping
content or having team meetings I could
be incorporating those things even right
now literally I'm sitting here recording
this podcast for you I could have made
this a Vlog about the entire process of
how I prepped this podcast filming this
podcast having someone that's helping me
so I you know even the idea of team
versus me as a solo Creator and then
what it looks like to publish this
podcast I could have made a vlog now I'm
kicking myself for not thinking about
this but I will now thanks to Aaron on
demand but I could have done that and
you know I pulled a stat when Aaron was
talking about the idea of
um you know the idea of repetition and
routine builds trust I was thinking
about you know as content creators as
business owners we want to be authentic
we want our customers and our community
to trust us and there was a statistics
actually uh that that proved this 88 of
consumers say that authenticity is
important when deciding what brands and
companies that they like to support and
46 percent of consumers buy based on
trust alone that's huge and I think
having these types of formats being a
creative Creator can allow you to go
deeper with your audience to build more
trust and I think about that often as
we're building think media as a company
you know we've got different content
creators that started with Sean and then
it was Heather and then it was Omar and
then it was Nolan we're building these
different influencers basically but we
we want them to all be trustworthy in
the eyes of our consumer and so maybe
pulling back the curtain a little bit
more letting you into our worlds a
little bit more of like how do I do this
as a homeschool mom of three who's also
running this company in Ministry and
loves to travel with my family like how
could this be part of what you're doing
also Aaron also did a really good job
with this with her top three journal and
if you actually want more tips like this
that we're doing here we actually have
21 video marketing tips just like this
that we've exclusively put together for
you the people in our community so that
you can learn these skills and grow your
business through the power of video so
go to 21videotips.com to get access to
that now earlier in her talk Aaron
talked about her top three journal and
how she was incorporating that inside of
her Vlog it started with her writing
three of her top goals and because she
did that in every single Vlog this is
taking it back to that repetition and
routine builds trust she did that every
time she was posting a vlog she was
sharing her top three and then her
community started to Rally around her
and share their top three and she
thought huh I wonder if I if I'm like
this and my my community's like this
we're all struggling with trying to like
write our goals I should make a product
and she did she actually made a journal
called your top three and that's
generated over fifty thousand dollars
because she was just being repetitive
with the part of her routine that her
audience was clued into and this is
exactly what we see with some of the
best influencers garyvee does this you
know it's so cool to be able to watch
garyvee in his everyday but here's what
he's gonna do he's gonna be in meetings
he's gonna say something funny he's
going to be around his team he's going
to be you know encouraging and he's
always also going to be a little
abrasive like that's why Gary's Vlogs
always went he's bringing you along on
his process he's bringing you along with
what he's doing so I think this is
something to take heart in is this idea
that as we are creating this type of
content we're overthinking it we're
really overthinking it like we could
actually just be creating content with
the idea of repetition of what we're
normally doing in our everyday lives by
just writing it down ahead of time and
knowing that by doing that we could be
creating content around that so here's
the question for you what could you do
that's just a stable moment in your day
what could you do that's a staple moment
in the Vlogs that you're creating in
whatever the series is that you're doing
at the time all right let's get into
step number four and then step four is
creating a storyline based on the test
okay so if your task is packaging orders
some of those micro tasks under there
might be organizing products maybe going
on to Shopify to fulfill orders maybe
you're packaging the orders and then you
go to the post office to drop them off
okay if you're vlogging you have to
create a story okay so the beginning may
be it's Monday you've got orders in over
the weekend but you realize you ran out
of packing supplies so that's kind of
the hook that's the thing that makes
your story makes people pull through
your story so introducing conflict is a
good thing and it doesn't always happen
I don't want you to think that you need
to fabricate conflict in your Vlogs but
what I do know is that a lot of
YouTubers or content creators will omit
all of the the conflict all of the good
juicy stuff that you you just taking it
out because you want to seem so perfect
so you have to keep that stuff in so if
you if you ran out of stuff or if you
you know whatever happens like show that
and be authentic in that make it part of
your story
the middle you may go out searching for
packing supplies maybe you find them
maybe you don't and you take us through
your packaging process now the good part
about vlogging too is that you can still
add those bits instead of having one sit
down video about how to package orders
First Step this second step this you can
actually like Infuse those tips
throughout while we're seeing you
actually do it so maybe you give us some
value bits about customer service about
packaging you know your order some hacks
that you found the best pro the best
packing boxes or whatever okay and in
the end you successfully drop off the
packages at the post office all right so
this is more of how you take those tasks
and actually create a story out of them
so what I think uh especially with this
tip particularly is that this is what
vloggers that are winning do really well
there is a storyline and I love that you
know she wasn't sharing the entire day
she was saying no actually this is the
storyline it's all about the packaging
it's all about getting the orders out
and that is also you know subconsciously
telling people you have something to
sell your packaging orders there's other
people that want to buy this so I think
it's really cool that she was you know
even giving us the context around just a
simple task or a simple project a goal
that you're trying to complete and
bringing your audience along with that
and you know a lot of times vloggers
think oh or people that are vlogging
think oh well I can't do searchable
titles yes you can how to sell things on
Shopify is still a searchable title but
the content and how you deliver that to
your audience could be in a four-part
series all about actually getting those
orders to your clients so I think it's
really interesting how she was talking
about and this takes practice you know
this is simple but it's not easy and if
it was easy everyone would be doing it
but I think this is a challenge to us to
level up as content creators to level up
how we're thinking about delivering and
delivering content to our audiences and
actually growing a deeper connection
with them rather than having every
single video be exactly the same and
always just thinking about how can I put
out more and more and more and really
thinking about the connection really
thinking about building a brand which
means that they need a lot of touch
points with you which means that they
need to actually be a part of the
process and I think about some of my
favorite vloggers that I love to watch
Aaron being one of them is I've been
along for the journey with her and I've
been able to see her grow this company
become a CEO and build a team and get a
studio and get married and get their
house and all these things and by doing
that it makes me more invested in her
like I see the cool shirt she's wearing
I don't know if you can see it if you're
not watching this on YouTube but she's
got this cool shirt and I'm like I want
to buy that that's her merch and I'm
investing with her and I want to be a
part of what she's building so I think
it's really smart to be thinking about
how can you simplify it how can you make
it simple and how can you deliver the
content to your people all right let's
get into step number five and then plan
your Vlogs around big events um if
you're somebody who actually really does
not do anything
which I highly doubt most of you do plan
it around I highly doubt most of you
don't have things to do don't make I
know y'all ain't loners y'all plan it
around big events so photo shoots if you
have a big photo shooter if you have uh
your first client call or your first
client presentation or session if you're
shopping for Merch supplies if you have
work travel speak engagements in fact is
anybody vlogging today
okay okay yes this is the content you
guys this is like content heaven so you
know if you want to start a vlog and you
haven't really known the story is
already baked into this event like you
know take advantage of being out and
doing things and sometimes you kind of
have to create that like how we show in
the last slide so what big events do you
have when I think about even my life
this right now like actually just
filming today is more of a big event
than most days when I'm sitting in my
sweatpants at my computer planning
content or being with my kids doing
homeschool like this is an event me
actually putting on makeup getting here
planning the content being in front of
the camera
um but then what are some big events
that are happening in your life do you
have photo shoots do you are you meeting
with the client do you have a big
interview that you're preparing for uh
maybe you have a a Channel That's All
Around real estate or Finance is there a
new um a new course you're taking or
what does that look like in your life
that you could be doing and really this
takes prior higher planning there's one
thing I've learned from Aaron so far
it's that she's not just picking up the
camera and pressing record Like I said
before she actually is like making an
effort to plan this stuff out so this
means that before you go on that trip
before you get on that call before you
have to go to the post office that
you're planning out what this content is
going to be and if you actually want to
see Aaron's video of her experience at
growth video live if you want kind of
like that uh what would that be like the
Matrix right like that idea of like
she's talking about it and now you can
see what she did I'll make sure to post
that link down in the YouTube
description as well in the show notes of
the podcast itself so if you want to see
how she actually incorporates this and
does that with the storyline that was a
multi-day event and she made it into one
Vlog so you can learn from the expert
like Aaron to see how you could do that
and actually I was just studying her
video because I have several speaking
engagements coming up and I'm thinking I
want to Vlog these I want to share this
content and I want to share the behind
the scenes of what it takes to even make
it to some of these types of events so I
think that's a really key point now
let's get into the ending of this
section from Aaron ultimately you got to
put the you in YouTube y'all you have to
make sure that uh you can watch a
thousand Vlogs you can watch whoever the
best vloggers are you can try to imitate
them to a T and it still ain't gonna
feel right you have to find your flow
you have to find your flow and the only
way you can do that is through
practicing so you may have a few
dudded Vlog Vlogs where you just gotta
tank them things or you can actually
post those too you know just have to you
just have to believe in yourself and
make sure that you're making it unique
to yourself because once you start doing
it for you and doing it in your way and
not caring what you know however
somebody else Vlogs that's when you're
gonna start seeing your Vlogs just pop
okay yes you have to put the you in
YouTube I love that she said that
because that really is like why we're
creating content on the platform if you
are trying to build a personal brand if
you're trying to attract new clients New
Leads new new people to come into your
world then you've got to put the you in
YouTube people do business with people
that they know like and trust and
they've got to build that rapport with
you in order for them to want to give
you their dollars right they've got to
build that rapport with you in order for
them to want to invest on a level with
you and whatever you're selling at
whatever point that is I don't care if
it's a five dollar thing or a five
million dollar thing you you've got to
be the you in YouTube and with this I
love how she said just experiment like
what if in the next quarter you create a
vlog what if in the next year you commit
to four Vlogs what if you commit to a
series in your channel that's all in
Vlog format remember this is just a
format and at think media we teach you
16 different formats that you could be
doing for your videos this is just one
style and Aaron's been able to monetize
that style she's been able to grow an
audience with that style so this is
still a viable way to be sharing content
and I want to just dispel that you don't
have to have the perfect kitchen you
don't have to have the perfect Studio
you don't have to make sure that
everything is perfect in order to Vlog
because we need the you and YouTube so
if you're like me and you still haven't
folded your laundry that's sitting on
your dresser that's okay you can still
Vlog with that mess around your house
it's still okay and I'm saying that to
you as I'm preaching it to myself
because I'm still nervous to take the
camera and press record well I hope that
you liked this style of content here on
the podcast if you did let me know in
the comments section Below on YouTube or
let me know in the show notes and if you
haven't yet downloaded the 21 video tips
from marketing experts like Alex or
Mosey Patrick that David Aaron on demand
Vanessa Lao chalene Johnson and more you
can get all of those exclusive tips for
you at 21videotips.com thanks for
listening today's episode and we'll
catch you in the next podcast bye